fans of Taylor are well aware of her
classic bedazzled guitar that she played
on The Fearless tour the silver sparkly
axe has become one of the many iconic
looks that Taylor has made famous over
the years so when it came to the era's
tour it seemed like a no-brainer to have
a bedazzled guitar as part of the show
but Taylor went a pretty unusual route
when it came to having a new one made
for the tour her parents made it for her
she shared a photo on her IG story
before before the tour started and it
featured a couple of hands placing
silver rhinestones onto a guitar
complete with the lucky number 13 on it
Taylor's tongue and cheek post said
quote was my era tour crystallized
Fearless guitar made by a Artisans and
finely trained Craftsman b a
professional musical instrument
manufacturer C my parents with superglue
and a free afternoon and though she
joked that it was not C it clearly was